we're continuing today with our special
series about Argentina compromise
creciendo bonus bonus no salió me Sean
no in the mil dólares
[Music]
no cream on no me more um capping shame
of the kingdom Argentina is one of the
few countries in the world that is
undergoing chronic inflation inflation
that they just can't get rid of when you
look at the statistics it leaves you
speechless
the country has experienced high
inflationary processes for at least the
last five decades fifty years in fact
since the Central Bank of Argentina was
created in 1935 the accumulated
inflation amounts to this spectacular
figure that you see on screen right now
that's a crazy 256 thousand trillion
percent this is the result of an average
annual inflation of more than 60 percent
since 1935
[Music]
but why can't Argentines get rid of
inflation what role does the political
class businesspeople and citizens plan
all of this why is the dollar so present
in the minds of Argentine sois listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
Debu up first of all we need to know
exactly what we mean by inflation is
often said that there's inflation when
the prices of goods and services
demanded by a country's population
increase in a general manner that's why
does it happen and what causes this
phenomenon and here is where that
special tool that we all use to make
exchanges comes into play and that of
course is money everyone knows that
money currency was historically metallic
and it's value was given precisely by
each metals weight and composition like
copper silver or gold but obviously this
wasn't very practical so overtime notes
that could be converted into gold and
silver began to be issued as these were
easier to carry it divided and therefore
used the convertibility system was
implemented until the thirties when due
to the Great Depression countries
gradually began to abandon the
convertibility system finally in 1971
Richard Nixon gave it to the final punch
I have directed secretary Connolly this
was Finn temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar in the gold or other
reserve asset from then on the value of
bills became completely dependent on the
trust that the market had on the
economic power of the solvency of the
country that issued them that's why the
notes issued by the richest countries
usually lead to the greatest value and
confidence in the markets
meanwhile government's no longer have to
stockpile gold and silver to support
their currency the ends of
convertibility gave the government's the
chance to use that all trend of ours as
much as they wanted that's of course the
bill printing machine
up until then if a government wanted to
spend more they'd be that to raise taxes
or borrowing money however the end of
convertibility gave them another
possibility finance public spending with
the creation of new money that is what
is popularly known as running the bill
printing machine the reality is that
these days all you need to do is push a
key and boom you've created all of the
electronic money you could possibly want
of course this has consequences if
central banks are prudence and economic
growth accompanies the issuance of new
money the effects of inflation won't be
excessively damaging but when
governments pass that barrier that's
when a very very serious problem begins
suddenly an artificial demand is created
that pushes up the price of goods on the
one hand and on the other makes people
lose confidence in that currency the
results a bolting of inflation of course
the government responsible for this
situation never wants to acknowledge its
responsibility which is why in the end
it always ends up liming entrepreneurs
accusing them of being speculators and
being greedy so then comes the magic
solution which only makes things worse
and that's price controls Argentina
unveils price controls to tame inflation
and no don't think this is a new idea
not at all rights control in Argentina a
history repeated by different
governments from Peron to alfonsín
everyone tried to do the same and were
never successful
Eloy hemos hecho nada niente McConkey
areas in your prison I'm a Robbie's code
unearthed in 1902 which was enacted
before 2000 BC set prices wages and
interest rates which means that price
controls are at least 4,000 years old
Henry Hazlitt
of course as this doesn't work either
and prices go up even more politicians
usually start raising salaries through
decrees and spending more on every kind
of plan and all of this is backed with
even more unpacked money being issued
it's a vicious cycle that only leads to
more and more inflation which means
destroying the value of savings
destroying a country's capital
annihilating legal security preventing
businesses from making calculations
which are vital for decisions and
depreciating the national currency and
few countries in the world know this
process better than Argentina the land
of inflation we told you in several
videos that Argentina's economic
situation is terrifying Network low
wages high taxes disastrous public
accounts and above all a lot of
inflation folks
Argentina's high inflationary process
has been growing steadily since the
1950s Argentina on the podium year after
year inflation of 51.3% is the third
highest in the world behind only
Venezuela and Zimbabwe
now can you see the process we just
described who on earth is responsible
for this inflationary spiral well check
out this chart prepared by the economist
nicolas checque an auskey web we can see
the lack of control that Argentina's
public accounts are experiencing as you
can see it doesn't matter who governs
military civil perónist or radical the
result is the same every Argentine
government has devoted itself to
spending uncontrollably resorting to
both issuing debt first internal and
then also external as well as issuing
money and that's precisely what has
caused Argentina's current economic
disaster
[Music]
yes you heard that right not imports not
vulture capitalism not greedy
businessman the truth is that these huge
public deficits have been financed and
continued to be financed with a huge
external debt very high inflation rates
that is with the bill printing machine
check out this table where you can see
the average annual inflation rates that
each argentinian president has had since
[Music]
some presidents weren't in power for
long even less than a year others were
in the presidential chair much longer
presidents such as the well-known Peron
Videla or Alphonse in Cristina Fernandez
de Kirchner or Mauricio Macri were very
different but practically every
president had something in common very
high inflation rates this process has
become so constant that Argentines are
now used to living with huge inflation
of course that doesn't lessen their
disastrous economic effects at all
indeed it can make it even worse it's
logical that when you get used to a
quickly devaluing currency all market
participants act accordingly
entrepreneurs try to compensate for risk
for example by raising prices even more
the unions demand wage increases just in
case and the government in an attempt to
compensate for all the economic and
social problems that have emerged keep
approving all kinds of regulations
issuing debt in foreign currency because
of course the time comes when local
financial markets no longer serve any
purpose and continue to run the bill
printing machine and the problem just
accumulates and continues a kind of race
organized and driven by politicians in
which all participants lose especially
the poorest those who depends on their
salary to survive
and we can't fool ourselves a clear
result of high inflation is that it
destroys a country's competitiveness how
well first by consuming its savings the
local capital and then when governments
introduced restrictions of all kinds to
deal with the uncontrolled price
increases that ends up creating unstable
industries and economies that can't
compete in the world this folks is
precisely what is happening in Argentina
and that's why Argentina can't get out
of a crisis without getting into another
one is we're talking about more than 50
years of mistakes here it just seems
that Argentinian politicians they just
don't learn recurrent fiscal deficit in
2018 the state covered only 85% of its
expenses with actual income Argentine
debt is now close to ninety seven point
seven percent of the country's GDP and
is the highest in the region now the
question is do Argentinians have any
defense mechanism is there an
instruments that can help them protect
themselves from the stubbornness of
politicians and yes in a certain way
there is actually one so listen up
the dollar world you don't need to be an
economist to know that having savings in
argentine pesos is a very very bad idea
it's something that those of you who
follow us from argentina will probably
know so if your currency is losing value
by the day in such a significant way
then you have no choice but to look for
another currency to better preserve the
value of your savings and in Argentina's
case and for actually every other
country in the world with the same
problem that currency is the US dollar
the Argentine economy is de facto
dollarized it must be done for real
Roberto cata knows
in Argentina is usual for everyone to
know the exchange rate of the dollar to
the Argentine peso and for Argentinians
the dollar is important for several
reasons that's because the price of
products is closely linked to the price
of the dollar allow me to explain
Argentine import several goods since
with their own currency the peso losing
so much value so quickly practically
everything is traded in dollars which is
also the international reserve currency
this also happens with Argentine exports
the dollar is more stable and ultimately
becomes the reference units prices in
pesos like a crazy thermometer that
changes temperature constantly secondly
and most importantly the dollar is a
currency that allows Argentinian stupid
maintain the value of their savings yes
it's true that the dollar also suffers
from inflation but it's in proportions
that can't really be compared to the
Argentine peso for example in 2001 if we
have saved 20 thousand pesos in a drawer
that would be enough at the time for the
average car by 2019 with that same
amount of money we could hardly afford a
smartphone and no it wouldn't be an
iPhone the loss of value of the
Argentine peso is simply spectacular
[Music]
so that explains why in countries with
high inflation the dollar circulates
almost as if it were a national currency
it happens in Argentina and even North
Korea used its dollars since 1950
Argentina has barely managed to go ten
years between 1993 and 2002 with
inflation at moderate levels below 4%
that's only ten years in almost seven
decades
thus Argentina has become one of the few
countries in the world that can't
control its inflation and make no
mistakes the solution is clear reduce
public spending balanced budgets and
stop being so dependent on the central
bank politicians know this the question
is why on earth don't they implement it
and this leads me to another question
will Argentinian politicians be able to
end this eternal spiral of inflation
well leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also please do check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel possible
because a patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider @ww re consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast